[Music]
being here I feel freer
preferring to come back here as I don't see
anything more than illusion
and not trying to fulfill that dream that
I am what I
saw of me passing
[Music]
river water when it never walks
properly
makes sense correct o  that goes forward
then Let's go backwards
[Music]
it was like a vein in my body
that transmits blood from the heart
or mother I live in worship
[Music]
it's very beautiful I really like this area
and I'm a fisherman
I used to do it to feed my  home
is to help and plow to be my friend
and hake to make a knife ax to sell
inside the animals here was too much
but the elephants
jaguars zebras kingdoms
here was a lot
hunting is being like the vice of the
territory
not long ago we had this
area full of animals
[  Music]
the Cavango delta in northwest
bolsonaro is one of the last
untouched wildernesses in Africa
[music]
covering up to 22,000
square kilometers depending on flood levels [
music]
wild buffaloes lions
[music]
and the largest population of elephants in the world
world
[Music]
annually about 2 million
tourists travel to botwana many
to see this oasis of water and its
abundant wild life in 2018 alone
tourism contributed 2.5 billion
dollars to the economy of the porpoise and
secured more than  80,000 jobs
[Music]
[Music] [
Music]
Barroso [
Music] [
Music]
people wildlife and an
ecotourism industry flowers
if it dries up all this ends
the water that floods the delta starts in the
southwest of the Plateau of  Angola I
went through Namibia to Boto Seu
Ana and ended up emptying
it is in the middle of one of the driest places
on earth its survival
depends on water
National Geographic explorer
Steve Bois founded the
National Geograph Wildlife Project to
try to ensure  the future of the Delta
learning about the rivers that feed it The
complex
[Music]
systems
of the world
a natural water tower composed of
hundreds of streams that start in the
Angolan Plateau and supply trillions of
liters of water to the famous rivers of the
African continent
and the Ambev
[Music]
but until 2015 it was very little explored
by scientists
[Music]
almost three decades of civil war
that left the region with hundreds of
thousands of land mines
[Music]
in 2015 the horse wildlife project
started to explore the springs
of the  Horse Delta
[Music]
[Music] [
Music]
more than 6,000 km
and carried out the first research on
biodiversity to understand this
unique and fragile ecosystem
plus an important river that they have
not yet explored
and the most remote and mixed of them all
the river when it is known for its
hippos floodplains and the
possibility of having land mines
[Music]
to successfully navigate this river the
team hopes that the lutezem fishermen
can help guide them safely
through this landscape
[Music]
for fear  Plus
the team
carries out assessments
among those responsible for the Canoes
there are Botswana guides and some
local fishermen hired for their
excellent navigation skills and
knowledge of the area
welcome
my name is Kailane Costa I am a beautiful
project as director for Angola
[Music]
9th time  that I'm doing an
expedition of this kind
[Music]
discovering Angola and documenting Angola in
a scientific way in the other way
of writing it's really a dream
something I've always wanted to do for
children
encounters
failures in supply many
unknowns
[Music]
at first I  I felt worried
because there was no way for me to understand for the
first time
[Music]
and I also want to learn from him to
explore what he promises me to explore
with him
Chicão
while The teams travel down the Rivers
they take note of all the
animal sightings
together  with the collection of fish and
reptiles
and water quality tests
for one evening a picture of the health of this
ecosystem everything you do here
every type of survey will
help other generations
we need to know it to protect
the team
they gave us a place  more trees
[Applause]
[Music]
and they are weeks behind the
river team when Steve
was the beginning of an obstacle that is a
bet that we always have each one who
walks on water
happens every day and that is
a destiny  of the man
crossing the river and We saw that there were
hippos about 150 meters ahead of
us and, afraid, we usually stop to give the
hippos time to feel
comfortable with our presence and to
show us which side of the river we cross
we have the habit of thinking that  we are we are
in the jail bell
that hippopotamus with vulnerable life
is how valuable life is and with i must
respect nature
whether encounters with hippos or
trees blocking the river
both teams have had their share of
emotion
despite all the jobs despite
all  physical stress all
psychological
This is the best way to document
the river valley the forests around the river there
is no way to make a mess
and if we make the right decisions in
terms of conservation we can achieve
what the button
I decided to see for  on these expeditions
because this is an area that has never been
explored before or even documented
I become but the first or only
photographer to have the opportunity to come
here to document and wash the images so
people can get to know their land
from a broader perspective
a lot of people don't know what there is this
paradise that we must protect
[Music]
I come with the mission to bring images
and be able to tell more stories to
people from Angolan to Angular in
our non-Portuguese language but in a
way that we all understand
[  Music] we have
n't seen many animals we
know they're here
like the Christ team we're late
I'll have time to assemble some
layers
our scientific team has already assembled
hundreds of cameras with
motion sensors since 2016
although the cameras don't give any
indication  of population density and abundance
these images are still
good records that these animals are
here
and of course animals that are more
predisposed than others
we are super excited some
iconic species from africa are
in decline in other parts of the
continent like a lion alleys
and cheetahs
sometimes predators need prey they have
a very strong competition
[Music] [
Music]
normally hunters light they make
fires
but then leave fire
without extinguishing then fire
goes down
[Music] [
Music]
[Music]
after almost 30 days the team  from
Crazy finally catches up with Steve at the
confluence of the rivers and when
[Music]
goes well
from the road
he will return to the capital to
meet with government partners and
work to secure the future of this
landscape
[Music]
Christmas will give him the  rest of the
expedition
I think the animals were closer
to men
because men were not interested in
killing so much meat there
was just a need
[Music]
is necessary and wartime
I was kidnapped in 1998 I
stayed in the grape column the crossing phase
of the  Rio when
transferring material from the other
side to the other,
we took the tank mine boxes
and personnel mine boxes and
knowledge of aque and G3 ammunition we did
not generate children at that time I was
8 years old
to destroy and the only thing that  it was the
evil of war on my side
[Music]
that we are enjoying these things being
very destroyed
and things are not very off-putting
for us
other animals only kill because
I also wanted to I thought it was bad
money
if there were more companies than the
men managed to earn their daily bread a
thousand times we stopped hunting
and not to defeat living lives
being like family
[Music] it
is for me to get what it is like to survive
because here in the world
[Music]
to live this friendship
the river when it is made up of a vast
floodplain something that can make it
difficult to find a place to camp [
Music]
work [
Music] [Music] [Music] [
Music]
[Laughs]
[Music]
me  I used plumbing,
electricity and refrigeration technician
rapists and quarries
I arrived in Luanda for the first time I
was very scared with the city
I had the illusion of knowing it and
another good road like the houses
building
s more different than I had ever seen in the city
my life
[Music]
better we are goods but in health it's
living hard
but being in this Forest with the
trees has a flavor
that makes me feel like I
live as if I were a person who
improves more than everyone else that's why
I  I fit in a lot in this
territory and the Natal territory
[Music] [
Music]
has two
[Music]
orange is in the water too but there is
another one is in the water has a little bigger
neck is longer he points the
neck like this
[Music]
no  learning soon I'm going to
lose my job
Let's think
[Music]
I'll tell you everything Elias about our
scientific work the unique species
we find and all the discoveries
we make over these layoffs
4 years of scientific exploration is starting
to pay off for scientists  from the
wildlife project
[Music]
maybe
[Music] [
Music]
in this basin [
peat watersheds estimated to be some of the
largest in Africa
these deposits function like a
giant sponge storing trillions of
liters of water that are
slowly released to  ensure a
constant flow of water to the
alcavango delta in the video box
[Music] [
Music]
and with these secrets of vegetation of
birds began to appear Secrets
also about the local communities
people who have always lived on these islands
people who may have left with the  war
but they're back now
[Music]
a key role
the locals are just
trying to survive and it's new for him to
know that wild animals
[Music]
can help local communities in
a way that achieves that Harmony
between development  human and
nature preservation
[Music]
the team crosses a large
floodplain that is reminiscent of the delta
[Applause]
we managed to find on the map what
looked like Islands taking a risk and taking a
different path
and we found this island and we found it
strange because the island was  full of
lemon trees
in the middle of the river
the team's rice and beans is a welcome change
that night the head of that area and
his wife visited the
team camp Elias told them about the team's mission
and the soba spoke about his role as
The Guardian and protector of the natural world
[Music]
and he told us that those Lemon Trees
had been the result of interference from
elephants ie
elephants ate from the Lemon Trees and were
spreading with their faeces through the
flood valley And so Those Lemon Trees
actually grew from  from the
elephants' droppings and created those
fruit forests
these countless lemon trees some footprints
and dung
indicate that there are some herds of
elephants that migrated here [Music]
the landscape [Music] [Music] [Music] [
Music]
[Music]
[Music  ]
we need to conserve animals
conserve the forest by raising Quali the
most important use for us to conserve
that territory
[Music]
after four months the team reached the end
of the Angolan part of Rio
[Music]
with our  research on these rivers
has shown that these ecosystems
are still healthy full of
biodiversity still connected
[Music]
for this area to become what was
once
a paradise in Angola
Paradise for our children
[Music] [
Applause] [
Music]
[Applause]
[Music  ]
[Music]